all right Jimmy
yes Jimmy where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
I was born in Simi Valley but um I grew
up in Orange County
tell me about your family your both your
parents
um at first yeah
until I was like um
I think my dad
uh got arrested when I was like 11.
and so when my mom broke up after that
how would you describe your childhood in
general
[Music]
like a
tornado
what kind of stuff was going on
um
I never got to be a kid uh
my dad um was a cook for a biker Club
and I thought everybody had a yellow
bathtub
they weren't allowed to use
um he could crank
and when he did or he didn't have it um
our house was
just out of control
he used to um
uh
barricade himself in the house and
he had a
a schizophrenic character in his head
named Fernando
and um
yeah he's just a really
he's just shoot it up I remember
I used to have to be the parent a lot
until I tell my mom on him a lot because
she stayed home with us
um
me and my little brother and sister
um my mom was a hairdresser
and um
she kept herself really busy because
because he made her crazy
was there any abuse yeah
he just um he used to beat my mom up all
the time
[Music]
he threatened us
um
that he was going to beat my mom up if
we didn't do this or that
um
and
um he just he used to play like nasty
games with me
and like my number one goal in life was
to never let my sister be alone with him
I think I did a pretty good job of it
um
I swallow around and
I speak so like addicted to like
um not letting my sister get hurt that
like
I wouldn't even let her um
like spend the night at any friends
houses or anything like that because I
was scared that he wasn't even going to
pick her up or
something like that I had to be like a
couple steps ahead of him
um
but you took the hit for your sister oh
yeah
yeah I just never wanted her to she's a
nurse now and she has like two kids and
she's normal
and you're here in the streets
how long you've been living like this
[Music]
um
I ran away from
a program uh
I think and um
I know how long now I think it's been
like
four or five years
that I've been out here on the streets
before that I
I was in Garrison New York
um
and then
North Carolina for like 10 years
have drugs been a part of your life
yeah since I was 28
how old do you know
um I'm 41.
only I just look really old
because I I feel really old
these streets are like killing me
it's rough out here and so rough
especially for a woman
can't sleep anywhere
and feel safe you know
it's like you want to be in the dark but
then how dark do you want it to be when
where no one can see you you know
or you want to be quiet but like how
quiet so no one can hear you or you know
there's so many crazy guys out here that
are like
shooting up Crystal
and ready for some action and
the total opposite of what I feel like
I'm ready for it you know
and um it's just it's scary I've never
seen more crazy people in my life like
people that actually lose their mind
um I remember just being at this train
station the other day and being like
there's three people in the bathroom
that were talking to themselves and I
was like when I was a little girl and my
mom took me to the train station I don't
remember anybody talking to themselves
like this
you know it's like something's wrong
like something's different yeah
definitely mm-hmm
it's all over the country too yeah
it's not just la
because they they lose it either you
lose it or you don't like
you know and you can watch people come
out on the streets and then
day by day
lose it more
and they don't think they are you know
but you see it like
it's it's scary what's the worst thing
that's happened to you since you've been
living like this
oh
I think um realizing that like demons
are real and um
into the opposite and God's real too but
like I never
I never saw sat and thought
like that it wasn't a fairy tale or
something like something just to scare
you
but being out on these streets at three
o'clock in the morning three three four
o'clock in the morning
[Music]
um
and if you still don't believe in demons
you're [ __ ]
because
um they're real and they're out here and
they're strong and the person doesn't
even know that they have them or that
they're a part of it they're just like
if you tell them what happened last
night they're like
really like they don't have any idea
yeah it's a different world at three or
four in the morning isn't it oh God
at this hour it's kind of almost it
appears like it might be somewhat safe
yeah can we walk down the street with
your kids or something you could but at
night it's a different thing okay yeah
yeah I know I don't know
why they feel more comfortable at night
but they sure do come out and
get Brave you know
I don't think they necessarily even hurt
people they just um
scare people or something
do you have children
of three
and where are they
they're with their dad
um
they're not really children anymore
did you raise them at all
up until my oldest was 11.
and my little one for like eight and
seven
so no not long enough you know
I never thought that I was gonna be one
of these parents
that we were kids
but it was supposed to be like really
quick I was gonna go to rehab and I was
going to get better and then I was going
to come back and
I just never got better
and they never fixed me
what emotions do you deal with
not very many
did drugs help with that
I usually don't let myself get even just
sober it's just that
it's really hot outside today
and
but the minute I do
start to have feelings I just I can't
really handle it
did you describe yourself as
self-destructive
oh yeah
yeah I I feel more comfortable
sleeping on the park bench in MacArthur
Park than I do
in a beautiful house with beautiful kids
and I never felt like that was my life
or that I should that I deserved that I
don't know why
your friends
no
what do you worry about what are you
afraid of at this point of your life
um
just that I'm gonna um
I'm gonna die out here and somebody's
gonna have to tell
my kids that
I was murdered or something horrible
happened to me
and I know that's probably gonna happen
who are your favorite memories as a kid
um
my mom and dad they had this um 10-year
like mirrored free dedication thing and
they
were both going to church and um like we
were like caffeine the the clean
eventually
um
at one point
my mom eventually died of an overdose um
of morphine and Xanax and um
and my dad's feel crazy in North
Carolina like with a bunch of cats
living in a trailer somewhere
yeah
it's just the roughest point of your
life right now oh yeah
supposedly God only gives you so much
that you could handle and like I don't
know what he thinks
um
or what he knows but
um I just wish he'd give me a break or
kill me
you know do you believe in God yeah
I would think it'd be hard to believe in
God seeing what you've seen
it's either harder it's easy
I don't think he's like Santa Claus you
know
um but I don't think that
there's not an opposite to him who this
is his world you know
and um
somehow we're here and we're supposed to
do something
and I'm obviously not doing it
it's because it's not going so well
how do you think your time in the
streets has changed you
humbled me Beyond like
I mean
to stand with the sign is probably the
most humbling
thing I've ever done in my life
I'm just asking a pure stranger for
for help you know um
is that how you make money
no I used to but I I
run in and out of stores with handfuls
of clothes and merchandise boosting
boosting
every day yeah
thousands of dollars
so many people
stealing from stores now it's
it's got to be hard to be a shop owner
oh it's so embarrassing like I think
about these people that are just like
watching
the other day this late I was by this
staircase and I was just shoving
my bags full and I heard her on the
phone with maybe her girlfriend or
something she was oh my God you should
have saw this girl she just put
hundreds of dollars worth of stuff in
her purse like it was nothing and little
did she know it wasn't like it was
nothing it was killing me inside you
know but I I had to focus on something
and I don't have really a choice
because it's either
um septic or boost and
I'm not doing the other one anymore so
like
I don't have a choice you know
and if she was faced with the choice she
would probably do the same thing
but they don't get it they think it's
like for me or like all that stuff was
for me or
whatever
a little as you know I I'm still gonna
leave
the devices with the same amount of
stuff that they came up with which is
nothing you know
what do you think most people outside of
this lifestyle don't understand about it
that um we get paid pennies
and it's not for us
and no one
wants to do this a lot of us are like
upper white
or middle class white kids that
have a bad drug habit to Fentanyl
and were
tilting our moral compass to
get through our day so we can eat and
sleep in and pay for our drug and
um
and what looks to you is like fun
because we might smile or laugh um it's
what we have to do to like not cry
because when somebody says ma'am ma'am
ma'am are you going to pay for that
everything in me wants to be like yeah
put it on the money you know or
or you want to stop and give them their
stuff back
but I just keep reminding myself it's
not theirs and
someone's going to claim out of their
insurance and whatever I have to tell
myself you know to justify it
is there a lot of shame that you carry
around oh yeah
especially since like I'm visually
recognized by a lot of the stores so
it's like very shameful
you feel like life is unfair sometimes
prepare
um
I don't know about unfair because I
might remember some things I don't
you know
um
I think that
I think that um
there's only so much somebody could
handle though and then and then what
like
am I supposed to go crazy or am I
supposed to just get sober
I think I'm at the point right now where
it's like it's not getting any better so
I have to start making choices like
this is the way it's always going to be
I gotta change something yeah it seems
like there's drug addicts and then
there's fentanyl addicts which is a
whole nother
ball game yeah much harder to quit
it's not even an option
on your own do you think I know it
they made it so
I don't think you think it's gonna it
could be an option these people that do
it in jail see like gel is very mental
and your your mind knows like you're not
gonna get it so it doesn't give you the
symptoms as hard but if you're going to
be out here on the streets and think
you're gonna get off at no you're
tripping
I mean
it has to be with like one of those um
what do they call that like the
controlled
methods or whatever yeah like jail
sometimes I feel like oh God when when
I'm about to get arrested you know I
feel like oh maybe you know in the back
of my head I'm like okay here I go and
then they don't take me ever
you don't stay
no I've never been taken to jail oh is
that right
because I look at my legs
and they don't let me in their car
yeah tell me about your legs
they're just um
that was just for me you know leaning
into them when we were talking
but they're all edema
and
heavy
they're swollen from what from fentanyl
I guess so
I don't know what else it's probably
mostly water retention yeah it's all
edema all
water
and then they start to have sores on
them
infection
and they burn and
itch and then during the night I'm gonna
scratch them and
poke and prod them you know and when I'm
not realizing it or when I'm high and
then I pay for it later you know
and it just keeps getting worse
and I noticed so many people
with it
and then I see them in a wheelchair and
then I see them not
um even in a wheelchair
they're like in a hospital somewhere or
I don't know what happened to them
what they call it um
cellulitis
what's your biggest regret
oh
um
justifying and um
keeping a little secret of
um
pills
and
just not letting anybody know how I was
feeling thinking I can
keep it under control
they got a lot of good people around me
then and um they would have helped me
before did you protect your dad when
this was going on
as a child
oh yeah sexual abuse
oh yeah
I have it in my head that like
that that's what I'm here for
something that's my worth you know and I
don't have really any self-worth and
that's a big deal
it's a big deal of like what you put up
with as a human yeah yeah that led you
into sex work when you were younger
yeah
yeah
it's only certain kind of girls that can
do it
somebody that can like shut themself off
and um
and and and put a price on their own
body
I learned that most women can't I
thought everybody could
and most women can't
and Jamie what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
[Music]
um
no matter what you're doing
just try to do the next
best right thing
because karma's a [ __ ]
thanks for sharing your story because
thank you